[Music]
right now
guys i gotta go uh i gotta go like make
sure my kids aren't able to get out here
it would be terrifying they'll be still
so sick they'll be so scared of this
look
when the storm chase happens i'm so
excited for this hold on
[Music]
all right there we go there's the link
let's go i'm going to do a twister quote
f5
finger of god
if he gets the reference i'll die
laughing all right let's see let's see
let's see let's see please please beat
somebody gets it
he has to
so he's driving in this bad weather and
reading his chat this is awesome
this is an lgbtq friendly stream
it's dorothy in the back of the truck
great reference andrew great reference
i think some of these comments might be
a little questionable
they're twister references they're not
even mean doesn't even mean
i'm assuming somebody here is a
die-hard twister fan yes
yes
yes yes yes
[Music]
hold on i'm actually very curious let's
hear him don't be mean to this guy
because he got the twister reference i
kind of want to figure out what he's
doing before we
we figure out what we're doing
right behind me nice yeah the brain is
visible isn't it
this guy's not a terror reader he's just
the guy who likes chasing tornadoes i
guess
it's a humble job
dude he only has 120 subs no no he has
121 subs now
dude everybody dude he's a storm chaser
this is awesome i think hey i found my
first small youtuber that dude this
guy's good i just sucked this is perfect
dude a guy whose entire youtube is
chasing storms is amazing
early in the day for that
a lot of people this fan are die hard
twister fans is very funny
okay you guys are just quoting every
part of the twister movie now you're
just writing the script which is so good
they call me hydroplane slim for a good
reason hydroplanes happen
are you single
i can't play any music when i'm when i'm
streaming
that's okay dog that's okay dog i can
boom got you
should probably stop after the doors
getting me popped
which one there's two of them another
cow
my favorite another cow he's calling out
the cows
my favorite twister quote was what a
twister that one
they never said that in the movie pessy
i can't play anything i think they said
it like like three or four times
no i don't exactly it's not what they
didn't go that's like saying in jurassic
park they said that's a dinosaur
no they said what a dinosaur oh that was
you're getting the quote wrong all right
what about what about this quote royce i
just typed it is that a good quote
is that quote from the movie let's see
i'm waiting for the pop-up
i guess the real twister were the ones
we made along the way that was never in
the movie
you got right at the end you got that
from you got that from a generic art at
an airbnb no you just didn't watch all
the credits it comes after the credit oh
like a marvel movie oh you're right yeah
you know what i'm not caught up in the
twitter that's how they set up the
twister too i i'm not caught up in the
twister verse you know twister versus
hurricane i didn't watch that one
no you see you see you you you did it
wrong
you're supposed to watch
you're supposed to watch deep impact
then twister then you go back to
armageddon then you watch deep impact
backwards okay and then sharknado and
then sharknado and then twister makes
sense yeah but only if you listen to the
dark side of the movie
the eight-bit version he's talking about
ham
yeah
if you're seeing twister in theaters
okay i have to wait a few years before
sharknado okay pesky what about my quote
i just posted a quote tell me about my
quote okay
wait is my favorite tornado
i'd probably say a nice lp
a [__] [__]
so your twister has just been revoked
your twister's just been revoked
that was in the movie right
fully condensed to the ground a little
dust swirling
all right what about the dude
tornado right there
okay let's see that's i like the twister
drums
this man is about to die and you guys
are [__] quoting movies
black guys like a twister's eyes let's
see that wasn't in the movie
i'm just gonna start i'm just gonna
start this quoting twister in my
everyday
to go all the way to life to get it i
like this guy he sounds like john c
reilly
hey there i made one how about that one
okay hold on
if you make it twister will come okay
hold on frozen here's mine though tell
me what you think about mine
i just posted one too tell me anything
about mine okay
you want the twister you can't handle
this
you killed my mother you killed my
mother you killed my father you took my
father's sword and then they attribute
the quote to twister thank you john h
that ego that's not a twister this is a
twister that one's for the movie twist
dude what about that one royce i came to
kick ass and chew twister and i'm all on
ass
every time i think i'm out the twister
pull me back pulls me back in camera
chris
frankly twister i don't give a spin
mickey froot loops
we can't stop here this is twister
country rusty shackleford
first you get the money then you get the
power then you get the twist
i'll say hello to the twister for you
hopefully i see one
hey i said about this one bud
see the twister it means not welcome
i'm gonna make a twister they can't
refuse and they attribute it to michael
mallis
oh
say
say hello to my little friend from the
movie twister
64 degrees out right now
all right enough we're done
enough
swear to twister that was one of them
too right
is there a sign outside my
outside that says dead twister storage
guys that's racist you could say twist
up with an a
oh yeah
i must not fear twisters fearing
twisters is the mind killer fearing
twisters is the little death that brings
total obliteration i will face all
twisters
you think you like twisters i was born
in one
is he gonna die
bro he's just driving he's like not just
driving on this wet road right but he's
driving pretty fast
bro virgie and reading the chat
yeah i love this guy this guy's a
[__] maniac
there's a there's been somebody in this
chat the whole time telling him to slow
down
hey director jan de bont you know that
twister you've been looking for well
listen guys everybody please subscribe
to this guy
please
this guy is a gold mine i'm telling you
i am become twister destroyer
[Music]
i'm the guy with the twister
welcome to indiana i am in indiana
you're also drifting
like kind of close to the edge of the
[__] highway
the twister doesn't want to be fed the
twister wants to hunt
road work ahead yep
i'm twisting myself andrew ditch
yeah
dude doesn't he sound doesn't he sound
like uh
yeah he sounds a little bit like johnson
riley yeah
yeah we're just chasing the storm right
now
that's not a great john c raleigh that's
a better kermit
actually it's a kind of [__] kermit too
it's like in the middle of what's he
doing
kermit the frog and then that's like
yeah deborah ah deborah
that's ray romano
so what's john c riley like deeper
i don't know i'm not a john c reilly
expert i just know when it doesn't sound
like him
i don't know royce it says that on your
linkedin oh [__] i gotta update that
john c reilly specialist like they
always have whenever they do one of
those like documentaries they always
have somebody with a weird title like
john c reilly historian
okay now he can't even see out his
window dude
i don't know if what this guy's doing is
super safe
no he's fine he'll be fine
or he won't
i love him i love her i love a virgi
he's just like no he'll be okay or he'll
die
he'll die i mean we don't know
bro and there's construction on the road
jesus christ
why is this guy driving to a hurricane
into a twister
i mean
because he's a storm chaser
i get it but i don't remember them live
streaming in the grand in the oscar
award-winning film twister yeah
well they didn't have the budget for it
oh you're right you're right you're
right you're inferno
it was either helen hunt or iphones and
i think they chose correctly yeah
absolutely
js if it twists we can build it okay
that's not from the movie i don't think
what's the difference between a twister
and a tornado that's a good question
actually
about five dollars am i right okay well
the twister has tire tracks leading to
it
oh that's
the twister is near helen
there's like four super racist people in
chat that got that [__] yeah
i'm mad as hell and i'm not gonna twist
anymore so twist or two is going to beat
up tornado who won't he will he won't
bend the stereotypes and refuses to
twist
that
did you miss the exit
what gas station are you going to
i kind of want to see what this guy
looks like
yeah i only played the texas yesterday
but uh
quite the hall it's all it's just all he
does
in the locker
oh that's what he looks like
that's what it looks like oh okay
hold on
that's the twister guy
not what i expected him to look like no
autistic probably
but no the twister got him oh oh no wait
oh no he's fine
that there's a twister near
guys there's a twister that's near
oh no this is going to turn into a
horror movie
nope let's get it back oh the twister's
getting close
twisters are known for ruining cell
phone service
no
okay he's all right he's all right he's
alright he made it
no
the twister was coming from inside the
house
okay there was never a twister ever okay
hold on a second guys because i'm gonna
keep this up but what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna just show you the other videos
he's made so you can kind of see what
this guy's life is like i was gonna i
was gonna send you one of his more
popular ones i just put it in the locker
it's uh it's hip it's like a clip of him
actually like hitting one oh wow look
look at this one
this is him after a tornado he got to a
place after
that's pretty [__] nuts
all right so this is one okay this okay
i see what you're saying so let's try
that let's do this one so two years ago
apparently yeah
not for broadcast
sorry
yeah sorry bud we're just gonna be a
shitload of followers all right sorry
about this but we're doing broadcasting
okay this is happening
if you want exposure
[Laughter]
as he's stroking his head
i don't know what you're talking about
we're all a bunch of men here i don't
see a single broad
the yep there's the oh this is a monster
oh here we go holy crap
large tornado
large tornado look at the inflow over
here
oh [__] this is crazy
debris debris
we're in the air
the women really want to smash
look at that look at that look at that
[__] holy [__]
all right you're good
yeah we're gonna cross the road
all right
we probably shouldn't be in this fiat
that was a big big [__] too
uh-oh that was big
oh
some hit the car that was probably a
squirrel
[Music]
just in a storm holy [__] what was that
look over look over to the left sorry
i'll try to full screen for you guys
look over to the left
is that a turned car
yeah
yeah look look look
and it's on fire
holy [__]
[Music]
i think that's the rear that's the tail
light stock
not stuck it flipped oh yeah it's a
truck it's a truck yeah the wind got it
and flipped it
all right we need to go make sure he's
all right
look at that let's get out of the
vehicle i put another one in the locker
for you what the [__] i love how is this
channel not having more subs this is
awesome
junkies and twisters people stay waves
i'm telling you
holy [__] [__] no no no no hey royce
isn't that the area we're in on elden
ring right now oh my god that [__] was
right i am scared of [__] tornadoes
that [__] was on point royce what did
we learn the [__] are always right
about tornadoes
[Music]
so so royce go to his channel just do it
by most popular there's like there's
like this there's like ones where it's
like uh what is this one six foot pip
hit our
car and there's something like time
lapses this dude's [__] most nuts
popular
you know he was like like in the middle
of that storm why didn't he like put
those little ball things out you know
what i mean like dorothy yeah why didn't
he do the dorothy thing
why don't they just make the tornado out
of that kid
[Laughter]
i'm sorry guys um here's a touchdown
it's weird how sexually excited they get
about the tornado though
no it's not at all actually for you know
given the context true dude look at that
why else would they be [__] chasing
tornadoes
it's getting bigger
bro
that is just
a vision of evil that feels like an
elden ring boss look at that i'm telling
you man
it's [__] terrifying
definitely holy [__] and they're just
like and the thing is like i don't want
that and they're just going to it
they're like yeah let's go check out
these dangerous [__] storms
hey royce they just opened up a place
near you called
rape explosion sharp glass cut store do
you want to go i'm gonna go i've been to
busch gardens
i'm gonna say sea world's still open
yeah sea world's still open bro what are
you talking about
you can go if you want
it's right there
i need a battery pack dude oh it's a
battery pack it needs a battery pack
there's a tornado right there i need one
right now i don't care how dead it is
here's what's very passionate about his
tornadoes
yo that that changed very quickly
yeah rewind that a little bit
watch how fast that [__] changes right
there i need one right now i don't care
how dead it is
oh wow
and then the sky just falls
dude oh no you can't see now
it's [__] so wild
oh god it's the mist if he starts flying
come on hold on
[Music]
ah well you're gonna have to shoot your
son bud
[Laughter]
the crazy religious lady in the grocery
store was right you know you're gonna
have to shoot your son the military's
not coming you shouldn't wait promise
where is he real
oh [__] did you shoot your son the
military's here [__] oh damn now you're
a sun murderer
spoiler alert i'm like a 20 year old man
was that the thomas jane one
yeah yeah that's okay yeah i remember
that one it was depressing man i was
pretty old though right it's been a
while yeah very old
uh because thomas jane now is doing
daily wire movies
oh well you know good for him
10 minutes
of screen time in a daily wire film yeah
um this guy's still going
all right look here's where we're gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave this
open and i'll check back
here real quick real quick though i just
found a video at someone else but inside
of an f4 tornado and that's not an f5
that's not a finger of god
yeah what is he some kind of [__]
[__] oh f4 oh i'm scared okay talk to
me when it's in f5 hey maybe don't stand
on your balcony during the [__]
tornado [__]
why is he doing
oh here we go oh
it's not good
tornado
judging by the screenshot it gets by the
thumbnail it gets bad
oh i oh i could see i could see where
the views are exactly when it gets bad
right here
oh here comes
oh [__]
nope
you're getting out of your balcony
they're doing the experience what do you
say it's just an f4 it's just a that's
just an effort
f4
holy [__]
oh my god
it's not an f5 it's not an f5 that's not
a finger of god that's just you know
that just is scrotum
god is dragging his balls across this
village oh that explains
dude
yeah
what are you doing don't open this don't
go outside
oh he's left he's locked he was locking
the door so the tornado could open the
doorknob
yeah cause that's gonna help
look it's like it's like a vampire
tornado
tornado out you have to invite it in oh
tomatoes like a vampire
he's in the basement all he hears is
amazon delivery
go play with your friends if you need a
drink there's a hose outside who's there
not a tornado
it's your guys he said it's not a
tornado open it up open it oh
he looks through the people it's just a
floating mustache
mustache with the glasses
can somebody photoshop a fake face on a
cartoon tornado thank you
no just put the fake face on the box of
twister yes
tornado delivery
service take twister put the [__] the
glasses of the nose on it and change the
tagline to he's knocking
oh
wow that is [__] nuts dude those are
trees
yeah i think those are trees
and there's people that you live in
places that are like
called tornado alley like why would you
well high-five
you know why they're not uh there's no
tall buildings in torpedo rally he's
running down uh
why's that because people would [__]
jump yeah you're right
you're right oh god
this is an f5 yeah this is an f5
southwest of oklahoma city
may 20th that's just
it's a violent tornado
[Music]
what is there a passive aggressive
tornado
[Laughter]
no whatever i guess i'll twist if i want
to i don't know who knows
that's what the tornado was knocking for
he brought
[Music]
bro that thing is huge
maybe maybe go away from the tornado yes
okay north into the tornado royce no no
don't go kill the tornado
go away for the tornado rory for a
second yeah
hold on
oh who's that i think someone's at the
locker
let me go let me go look oh hey let me
look to the people of the locker let's
see
who's at the door
wait a second
i think that's a tornado in disguise
i don't know but it might be important
so
maybe we should just hear him out okay
might be about your car insurance right
i don't know i've been waiting for an
amazon delivery it could be that i might
have to sign for it oh i'm looking at
its nose it's my tornado accountant
so stupid you guys are all idiots
tornadoes
yes
jonathan tornadoes dean
no it would be like
windberg
[Laughter]
arie windberg
does your taxes and then blows them the
[__] away
how am i supposed to get my taxes done
you keep blowing them away
this is so stupid
if you keep if if you keep blowing my
tax documents around we're never gonna
get finished here